i i would prefer someone say i hope you
get raped
okay
whenever you flub a line just riverdance
river dance when you flood lines and
then you get them right back oh you got
that gun all the way up and that
sphincter
sigmoid colon yup yup give
subordinate subordinate coordinate
coordinate son coordinates
[Music]
now let's talk about this procedure
we want to make an incision directly
overhead diaphragm
and then i'm going to put my dick in a
diaphragm
[Music]
and crawling and i'll be crawling
crawling crawling and requiring
and firing and firing firing reload back
to land
back to land
baby forest whitaker don't say a word
and use your right hand to stroke his
thigh a little bit
that was just for me cut
it comes out when whenever we're done
with anything
all right there's this one type all
right you were thinking about you were
thinking about shigurt speaking about
trying to define it in my mind by which
i mean you're going to be getting
[ __ ] and you won't be receiving
receivable
and you won't be seated and you won't be
receiving a favorable review on hell
and you won't be receiving a receipt i'm
giving you a regulative
oh my god why do i look like jeff
goldblum's
nuts
i hate you peter peter
that's how coming was so damn easy
hip hop and chip chop tona tony danza
gonorrhoea
tony danza gonorrhea i don't know
nothing about these
um up chuck the boogie to the up why
would people think
and i don't know what these kids talking
about with the wu tang yin yang
wala wala bang bang justin bieber justin
fever fan club
sugar hill hill street blues blues crews
tom cruise
stuff you playing right now make a
brother snooze n-w-a-o
what do you know spectacular talking
about flash gordon
looking for the princess living on a
different planet saving the universe
stuff
sister mister sister sister grab a tiger
by the toe can't believe i missed the
bull malarkey run dmcc
theo wouldn't want to be uh the don't
stop the booger to the bang bang boogie
the up
chuck how [ __ ] talking about up chuck
ain't nobody talking about upshot come
on
dude you with long hair looks like one
of the bad guys from temple of doom
that is so true as hundreds of people
are
i'm [ __ ] weak i grew up next to a zoo
with animal mating calls a minister
right here out of your window
i sleep over his house and it's just
because i have you know flashback of
night terrors
oh that yeah that's right that was you
doing that not the giraffe
this [ __ ] must be in love with a
woman named dolly track
like if this was the dude he got a shot
right there
yo you can't scuba dive with no hoes in
your dick homie
[ __ ] you dude get the [ __ ] out of here
what are you doing it's not all right
[Laughter]
against slavery and the same would hold
true if they're asian hey guys
kwanzaa is a real holiday no matter what
we say white people are jerks and black
people are cool
i like big butts and i refuse to lie
about it watch amistad educate yourself
let it out
over bill they're not going to reelect
you with a crazy out-of-control daughter
aren't they
make sure you get in the ric and you
just went and hit a squirrel
my keegan my keegan
where are you going my keegan
larry's tires from scooters
the only we only sell tiny tires
if you're looking for regular-sized
tires don't come here
what up what up my favorite craig
what up what up it's my favorite craig
i don't know you man fast forward until
we're looking forward again
that's probably the best fast forward
until we're looking forward
you know we're not you know we're doing
the same we're not looking into the
camera okay
you don't even need a pigeon i i will be
the messenger
you can just i do mouth noises wrap a
message around my arm and i'm okay
i'm gonna i'm a drawer i draw he does
draw
with chalk as his medium there's a black
black people uh there's a difference
between and when there was the day of
video stores
what happened what happened right there
that's a snot comes out of your nose
right there
[Music]
hey
you